I find funny how the school system will
teach us how to memorize pages and pages
of useless and indoctrinated information
that we could literally look up within
seconds but they fail to teach us the
most important things in life like I
don't know creativity imagination
self-awareness how to love other people
communication skills how to challenge
ideas how to grow our own food how to
self-defend how to build and overall
just how to think for ourselves or
literally anything about money debt or
taxes or I don't know just finding our
passions and true talents in life but no
they teach us what to think and not how
to think just a thought you know the
unfortunate thing about that is uh is
the point that's being made there is
basically correct tell me it's not true
now but